Speaker 1: Speaking of non candidates, Ron
DeSantis from Florida, we know that he's adopted
a lot of Donald Trump's mannerisms and speaking,
including this accordion hands thing that Donald
Trump does very often. He also now seems to
be copying how Donald Trump says China. This
is like really, really weird China. Yeah. There's
a video that was much publicized yesterday of Ron
DeSantis taking questions at a digital Bill of
Rights event, and he seems to be copying Trump's
pronunciation of China. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: So that's that's there.
You also have the role of China in.
Speaker 1: Oh, what a weird what a weird society
we're in. Let's. Let's take it from the top.
Speaker 3: So that's. That's there. You also have
the role of China in tech with things like, like
tick tock. And this is something there, if you
look at the tick tock that they use in China.
Speaker 1: China.
Speaker 3: Is much different than
what they're trying to do in the
United States. With China, it's all.
Speaker 1: China, by the way. It's
really funny hearing scientists talk about
technology. DeSantis talk about technology
and foreign policy. He sounds genuinely clueless.
Speaker 3: Oh, very wholesome. Patriotic. In the
United States, they're trying to inject
as much garbage into this as possible.
Speaker 1: Yeah, isn't that bizarre? Like, this
is not the biggest issue, but it is very strange,
very, very strange. And Trump has a long history
of saying China in a really odd way. Let's say.
Speaker 4: China.
Speaker 1: China.
Speaker 4: China, China, China. China.
China. China. China. China. China. China.
You go over to China. China. China. China.
China. China. China. China. China. You take.
Speaker 1: So anyway, I'm thinking that this
might be really funny until we realize it kind
of isn't and the world is crumbling again. But
for the time being. This is an insane Republican
primary. It hasn't even really started. And it's
crazy. Donald Trump already attacking Ron DeSantis
slash meatball run, going after Nikki Haley in
new ways, which we will talk about a little bit
later. We have Ron DeSantis mirroring Trump, but
not yet announcing, even though he's leading Trump
in some polls while not being a candidate. Nikki
Haley announces early She's only running against
Trump right now, and yet she can draw not a single
distinction between herself and Donald Trump. It's
February not of 2024 of 2023. So this is going
to be a bonkers primary. And if nothing else, I'm
glad you'll all be here with me to observe it all.
We will have these clips that I played for you
on our Instagram. You can find that by searching
Instagram for David Pakman show. We're going to
take a very quick break. Neil, Valerie will
join me after the break. Maybe not a name,
you know, but a guest requested by many of our
viewers and listeners. It will be a fascinating
conversation. And then we'll be back with
more of the events of the last 24 hours.
We'll listen to a voicemail or too much taking
place today on the show. Glad you're with us.